foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
I don't think I would ever say this out
loud into a microphone but thank you
Donald Trump thank you so much you
helped
save our democracy
by making sure that the crazies of the
crazies were your candidates
were your backers the Q Anon caucus
you lost big time last night it is a
huge Democratic win not just a huge win
for the Democratic party but for
democracy itself
and yeah they're gonna point out wins
like DeSantis and Greg Abbott and JD
Vance
three
three three wins that's what you got
that was the Red Wave that's the Red
Wave we saw in deep red Texas and deep
red Florida you're excited about that
I mean the most disappointing race was
probably that JD Vance won
here's the thing
Tim Ryan did what democracy is supposed
to do
so is it really a loss
is it
he showed he showed Republicans last
night in a Republican state
what you're supposed to do
immediately without hesitation
now there may be some question about
some of these votes and some of these
tallies in some of these states
because it does seem odd the Democrats
even win in Lauren mober's District at
this point that's what it looks like
we're coming down to the wire here
there's still a lot of counting going on
because that's also how democracy works
we still got counting going on
takes a bit
but we got a lot of footage to watch
today but again I hope Donald Trump
[ __ ] runs
I told you this the other day I wish he
would have announced
on twos or on Monday at his rally
he announced that he's gonna have an
announcement you don't think that had an
effect
this country does not want trumpism it
does not want that [ __ ] it's sick
and tired of it
we don't want it
move the [ __ ] on now rather the
Republican Party actually does that or
not that's the question
and if we if we as a democratic
Coalition want an easy opponent to be
Trump is an easy opponent to [ __ ]
beat
he's such a [ __ ] loser
what a [ __ ] loser
the best part about it all is the
trumpiest of the trumpiest of the
trumpiest got their asses handed to him
fantastic
fantastic
mastriano got [ __ ] smoked
in Pennsylvania
the insurrectionist the guy was at the
Capitol trying to overthrow our vote on
January 6th
and he gets rolled up and smoked in
Pennsylvania for governor
pack your [ __ ] [ __ ] you too Dr
Oz
it looks like warnock's gonna win in in
Georgia even though
Kemp won the governor's race
and that says so much
so much but I'm not sure if it says more
about Herschel Walker or Georgia in
general
you should be excited this morning
for democracy
you should be excited that gen Z is
engaged that Jin Z is paying attention
to their civic duty that is a huge win
in this country
that an entire generation decided
to make sure to engage with their
democracy that is [ __ ] exciting
it's been a long time since we've seen a
Young Generation engage
that early in their entry into democracy
and just their civic duty
now the Republicans are good here's what
they're going to do because they're
doing it already this morning who's the
enemy who lost this election was it
Trump
or was it Mitch McConnell and Kevin
McCarthy who's to blame
well how in the hell is Mitch McConnell
to blame
for mastriano losing how in the [ __ ] is
Mitch McConnell I mean I love the Press
blame on Mitch McConnell all day long
you know that's that's a hobby of mine
but how in the [ __ ] is Mitch McConnell
responsible for [ __ ] Carey Lake
or the or the governor's race in
Michigan
if Carrie Lake loses which it looks like
Katie Hobbs may pull this out
we have the top Executives in Arizona
Pennsylvania and Michigan folks we have
a Governor's firewall
for 2024.
they're little [ __ ] stupid plan
to subvert our vote
is gone poof in a moment and the reason
why is because they're [ __ ] nuts
they're [ __ ] crazy
they're [ __ ] crazy this Q Anon
[ __ ] election denying trumpism this
America First Nazism
is just not what America is about
and they definitely definitely
definitely last night said take your
[ __ ] hands off our [ __ ] uteruses
and off our [ __ ] rights
get your [ __ ] hands off of it
and a lot of people are confused by this
because in some of these states like
Kentucky
they're still deep red blue Rand Paul
ran away with his race
here's the thing
in Missouri I'll give you an example
here's a good example in Missouri
we passed the recreational marijuana
amendment 3 on our ballot
it was a referendum
and then we elected
the most anti-marijuana person that you
could possibly put from Missouri in the
Senate
it's not supposed to make sense the
problem that we really have in our
country is people don't know what the
[ __ ] they're doing when it comes to
government they have no clue they don't
know that Eric Schmidt who won the U.S
Senate rate here here in Missouri would
do the exact opposite of what they want
nope [ __ ] clue they just don't know
they don't know and it's not that
they're dumb or stupid I mean some of
them
some of them most certainly are but a
lot of them are ignorant they're just
completely ignorant of what is reality
in politics because they don't pay
attention
now they'll pay attention to a thing
like oh we're gonna decriminalize
Marijuana Make It recreational ah we'll
pay attention to that
they'll pay attention to wait a second
you're going to take away our my [ __ ]
daughters and my wife's rights that my
mother and my grandmother had I don't
think so
they'll pay attention to that
and and
thank the god I don't believe in for Gen
Z but more than anything women
women in this country engaged
women in this country said enough is
enough of this nonsense
and they say to our democracy
that
is the foundation of Who We Are
is to collectively together tell these
politicians
what we think of them
that's the entire point of the
democratic constitutional republic the
entire [ __ ] point
that really is the tenement of democracy
in the first place
is we are the boss not you you do not
get to tell us
what our government is going to do
and if you try it we will fire you
last night there was not even a hint of
a red wave
not even a hint and I mean at the very
first when but Florida I mean really
honestly can we just like I don't know
build a wall and then make Bex go pay
for it at before
I'm only kidding
oh I'm gonna get hammered for that one
here's the thing
demographic shift
demographics change
sometimes rhetoric and propaganda seeps
in very deep
and we have we have a right-wing
propaganda problem in this country
but it's not as bad as we thought
the numbers are showing
that people aren't buying what they're
selling they're really not in some
places sure
in some places they're buying what
they're selling like in Arkansas by
Sarah Huckabee Sanders
Arkansas would be better off with a
potato being the [ __ ] governor of
Arkansas this [ __ ] bonehead
and they're going to learn it they're
going to learn Maybe
what it's like to and vote in someone
who's completely incompetent who is only
a mouthpiece for fascism
it won't go well for Arkansas it won't
but we'll prevail
the Democracy lives on another day
that is the message that was sent last
night I don't know exactly how these uh
races are gonna fall it definitely
um I think within the last hour and I
don't know how much it's changed because
accounting is happening and they're
getting down to the wire in these races
with like uh Herschel Walker and Warnock
um if Warnock wins that without a runoff
they're really they really have [ __ ]
their entire uh narrative that trumpism
people want trumpism in this country
because Warnock is not even going to
have to have another campaign against
Herschel Walker
um so we'll we'll see how that goes we
have some house races still waiting on
that to see if Democrats are going to to
make sure to secure the house even by a
narrow margin
now which looks possible
that the Democrats will keep the house
even without that there is huge cracks
inside the Republican party I'm going to
show you some video clips I don't know
if you've been watching on Twitter
some of these Republican pundits
these strategists they're [ __ ] pissed
and they're pissed they should be pissed
at themselves
really honestly this whole [ __ ]
nonsense of who's to blame
it's it's it's their [ __ ] propagandas
what's the blame you people have lied
and lied and lied to people for so
[ __ ] long people are sick of your
nonsense and your [ __ ] they're just
tired of it
so much so that they're willing to
[ __ ] go out and vote against you
just because you're [ __ ] lying more
than anything
I don't believe gen Z activated
because they they all of a sudden were
interested in government
they saw the danger of the lies
and the vile nonsense
demonizing demonizing lgbtq people
demonizing people of color
demonizing children
demonizing women making their own health
decisions it really was a stupid [ __ ]
strategy it really is dumb
even this morning Matt Walsh
Matt Walsh which we're not going to stop
talking about that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
that [ __ ] perverted
[ __ ] can't stop thinking about
children's genitalia it is [ __ ] gross
this [ __ ] Matt Walsh with the
daily wire says this morning oh look
DeSantis is the only one that took the
message the message of what to ban books
to demonize lgbtq people that's your
National message good luck with that
[ __ ] you might be able to win that
[ __ ] in Florida but you proved
last night that you can't win anywhere
else with that nonsense
so good luck to you keep that narrative
nominate Trump nominate him do it I dare
you what better situation would our
country be in is to for that
[ __ ] to lose again
and I know everyone's you know
concentrated on his indictments this
morning but let me tell you something
this indictment on Trump that happened
yesterday in this election is is is
sweeter
sweeter than any indict criminal
indictment that'll be brought against
him
well much better
trust me much better way way more
of a message was sent last night than
ever would be sent by the Department of
Justice or in the courtroom
he got [ __ ] he got [ __ ] trounced
yesterday
absolutely trounced
and I'm going to show you a video of him
knowing he was going to get trounced
you've seen it already if you haven't
seen it holy [ __ ] I can't believe you
haven't seen this but you'll see it
today here on the Tony Michaels podcast
and the shitless Roundup
Gabe Sanchez will be joining us
for the [ __ ] let's round up here soon at
the bottom of the hour but I am very I
told you I was confident and let me tell
you something if you are not if you do
not turn off tyt and David pakman and
some of these others out there who were
[ __ ] defeatist
turn them the [ __ ] off come over here
where we [ __ ] make sense
tell your [ __ ] friends that watch
that garbage to come over here until
they change their [ __ ] attitude
I'm calling them out on the carpet The
Young Turks David packman and all you
other [ __ ] just absolute defeatist
stop it
stop it you were not confident in
democracy it makes me think that you
question it it really does make me think
you question it
and I would invite any of them any of
them on this show [ __ ] yeah come on over
if David Patman wants to come on my show
I'll challenge him
he won't do it
we as Democrats and we as pro-democracy
Coalition and us as liberals need to
stop being so [ __ ] weak
stop being so [ __ ] scared who gets a
Brat's ass
just
throw the punches of the of an election
throw the punches of a campaign how in
the [ __ ] do you think we're gonna govern
if we don't win
how
do you think it's gonna be good
if you were to give the Republicans the
Senate and the house and then in 2024
give the Republicans the White House you
think that's going to help you
[ __ ] that [ __ ] even if it's a little bit
delusional [ __ ] them lean into it
National narratives matter
they [ __ ] matter
and you were a part of making sure that
narrative didn't stick you the audience
yeah yelling screaming to the microphone
every day but you are the ones who took
the message and carried it
gen Z took the message and carried it
You're the Reason
the people are the reason that we have
the results that we have this morning
and and going into today I I have a
feeling that we're it's just going to
get better and better I had a lot of
naysayers calling me personally
texting me
and I said just wait just be calm just
Just Be steady it's gonna be okay
there's not that many
[ __ ] boxes in this kind of people
believe in democracy folks they [ __ ]
believe in it
yeah they may vote weirdly even though
they believe in it but they believe
just beginning the example in some of
these states
with the abortion rights
in Missouri with the with the marijuana
and then electing an anti-marijuana
United States Senator
we're not all the way there yet we're
not out of the woods right I'm not
saying that this is that this is a sign
that we can let up
honestly we gotta lean in now more than
ever
because it's soon and I've been telling
you this as soon as this motherfucker's
counted as soon as it's counted and
certified and we know what this looks
like we got to change our focus a
hundred percent change our Focus 2024.
that's the next big one folks
and there's gonna be there's gonna be
some races in 2023 that are going to
make a difference and we're gonna have
to we're gonna have to lean into those
and have our voice heard
but 2024 is the year that these
Republicans are looking to
yeah
and we must win we can we will
just like we have since 2018.
Trump's a big loser
he lost the popular vote in 2016. he
lost in 2018. he lost in 2020 and now
2022.
why in the [ __ ] wouldn't we want him to
be their nominee why in the [ __ ]
wouldn't we let him want him to be their
party leader
let them Crash and Burn [ __ ] it
again I hope he runs I hope he announces
I hope he destroys his entire his entire
business I hope he it he destroys his
entire reputation because that is the
path that he is on and he ruins his
freedom really honestly
if Donald Trump would have slinked away
if he would have conceded in 2020 after
the election
conceded no big lie no January 6.
we'd have a Republican Senate and a
republican house today
there be many more Republican governors
today
the reason why we won
is because he's such a [ __ ] big loser
that's right because we're not over
fighting yet we have to [ __ ] make
sure that this country understands what
democracy is and that it's at stake
in every election
on every level not just the national
level not just the presidential race not
just the senate race not just the house
races those governors races Secretary of
States attorney generals your your local
legislators Pennsylvania is likely to
have a huge a huge gain in their
legislature of Democrats Michigan has
flipped their legislator
think about how significant that is for
2024 when they're trying to cheat when
they're trying to deduce fake State
electors again
and the Michigan legislators Democrats
think about the victories that we had
this week
for democracy not for democrats for
democracy
so be excited this was a huge win
because
[Music]
honestly I'm so excited that these
Republicans were so confident there was
going to be a red wave oh what a bunch
of [ __ ] idiots
so confident they were gonna run away
with this race and there was no way they
could lose any
any of these races
and it was Democrat win after Democrat
win after Democrat win and we're not
over it's not over yet they're still
counting they're still dims winning baby
count up them wins
and don't forget to point out those
losses you got me when you got these
[ __ ] out there on Twitter that
that were tweeting two days ago and
three days ago call them out on their
little red wave tweets
make them delete those [ __ ] or
shame them for them make sure to
screenshot them too don't if you find
one screenshot it don't just I mean
quote tweet it but make sure you
screenshot it so we got evidence of it
foreign
they [ __ ] the bed it's not surprising
they had the captain Cheeto dusk Cuban
on her
as the it's the crowner of the Kings
and he [ __ ] it all up the whole thing
Mitch McConnell weeks ago said that this
was not going to go well Mitch McConnell
is the happiest person in Washington
this morning by the way
Mitch McConnell I said it Mitch
McConnell is the happiest person in
Washington today
they're going to try depending on him
they're going to try to blame it on him
but he's not responsible for these
Governor's races he didn't select these
Governors what's that got to do with the
[ __ ] Senate he ain't got nothing to
do with the house he's not the house
leader
that's Kevin McCarthy and McConnell
McCarthy don't like each other anyways
and that's good folks
that's good this is all good for
democracy to make these [ __ ] have
infighting in their party
to make them try to figure out
who's to blame
[ __ ] them
let's really screw with them let's let's
this week let's blame Mitch McConnell
and Mark carthy this week as a national
narrative from the pro-democracy party
and then next week Let's do let's do
Trump okay
we could do that we can absolutely
change the narrative on them from week
to week to week to week and make them
continue to fight each other here's
another [ __ ] narrative DeSantis
versus Trump there's your goddamn
narrative
we can bang them up all year long next
year from here until 2024 we can bang
them up and divide them up
make them fight each other like
Democrats always do
we can stick together on this
because here's what we can do
if we bang them up and they can't win
elections
then what we'll do is we'll argue on the
floor of the house in the Senate
of codifying Roo
of making sure the children start school
at three instead of five making sure
that that college students don't go
broke trying to get a [ __ ] education
making sure that families in this
country don't go broke because they got
a [ __ ] medical bill that families can
live
off two one or two incomes in their
household because they can earn a decent
[ __ ] wage
that's what we can do
that's what we knew we can argue those
points when we win [ __ ]
we can argue those points when we win
and we can keep winning
the patterns there we have we have the
layout
it's all we have to keep doing
so I wanna I wanna really thank gen Z
they really showed up
um to do their civic duty I want to
thank women
thank you for engaging in your democracy
and knowing what was at stake
but more than anything I want to thank
Donald Trump for selecting the [ __ ]
that he selected and making sure to pull
them over the line the crazies The
Crazies the [ __ ] crazies it's
fantastic Donald Trump you are the best
thing that ever happened in the 2022
midterm you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
everyone stick around the shitless
Roundup coming right back right after
these messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
good morning to all the haters out there
I know you hate watching you
[ __ ] I see you
oh
stick that Red Wave straight up your
fast that's right I'm excited this
morning I'm happy
[ __ ] em
you should be excited too for your
democracy you guys did it you did it the
best goddamn audience in the whole wide
[ __ ] world right here at the Tony
Michaels podcast
you're the best and I know I know you
guys had a huge effect I know people
think there's not a lot of people here
there's tens of thousands of people that
watch this show every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter and
twitch and simulcasting from the might
just touch Facebook page also on our
Facebook page
at the Tony Michaels don't forget if
you're on Facebook go follow us over
there if you want to see fake Gabe's
stupid ass comments you gotta come over
to our page you got band I think on the
other one yeah I'm not gonna ban him yet
I'm not gonna ban yet fake gate keep
commenting you really did help pull us
over the line fake Gabe you don't know
it but you did right here on the Tony
Michaels podcast I was able to show how
[ __ ] dumb trumpism is with your
comments you never fail copy paste from
trumpism itself
you're the best audience in the whole
wide world wide world
wide world I'm so glad to have you every
single weekday for two full hours we do
this show
and I'm super excited for all the new
audience members out there that are
watching
um even if you're hate watching I know
you trolls are out there hate watching
um I see yes I see ya
so give the trolls a thumbs up tell them
you love them tell the hate Watchers you
love them because a lot of them don't
get in the comments because we have the
best moderators in the world that's
right not only do we have the best
audience we have the best moderators in
the world Robin Margie and MJ give love
to the moderators there in the chat
they are super important to the show
here if you're watching on YouTube
and they're lurking around and those
other platforms too so don't think
they're just on YouTube
[Laughter]
I love you guys
I'm so happy for our democracy
but we can't give up this is not this is
we should not get too involved in too
many Victory lamps
we still have a country to save
it's obvious that there are big swaths
of our country in certain States
that are still living in absolute
authoritarian delusion
so we can't give up yet this is not the
final Victory it is only one battle in
the war against trumpism
so we can't give up we have to keep
going we have to keep fighting it is
super important no matter what the
makeup is going to be
I'm here of this election the the
overall
knowledge is that trumpism failed
yesterday
they failed this is the first election
Nationwide since January 6. think about
that
so this 2022 midterm is the first time
that Americans had the chance to make
their voices heard since January 6.
and we here watched
and I I actually produced the the uh the
hearings for minus touch
and hundreds of thousands of people
tuned in to those broadcasts just just
our broadcast not including all the
other broadcasts from all the other
networks all the other channels all the
other broadcasts out there anyways
just just on our broadcast hundreds of
thousands of people watch those
broadcasts
and they took it seriously they knew the
risk they knew what was at stake
inside our constitutional Democratic
Republic
now I believe they engaged
you engaged
they listened to the cries the calls of
hey don't just use your ballot encourage
others to use their ballot
talk to them ask them questions
it was super important I believe that's
why gen Z and those activists in gen Z
were so effective is because gen Z is
willing to communicate on these issues
they're willing to hash out these issues
and they made those decisions to Go
activate and use their ballot to have
their voice heard
incredible
to see democracy at work incredible to
see it at work
when I when I was watching videos
yesterday and I posted several of them
of these universities with these
students lined up for hours and hours
and hours some of them
at in states where they had to be
pre-registered some of them were
standing in line to register and vote
that's [ __ ] democracy folks that's
what gets me excited about our state in
this country I'm very optimistic
yeah do we have our problems of course
we all know what they are we watch them
here every day we point them out we have
to give them sunlight to disinfect this
nonsense
but I'm very excited I'm very excited to
see
that our democracy is strong that our
fabric is still there
what is more exciting than the newest
generation coming into leadership in
this country which by the way they
elected the first gen Z
person of Congress but seeing
seeing this new generation and they're
excited about engaging in their
government they're they're excited to be
educated on the civic duty that they
possess
which is the ballot and the access to
the ballot
rights freedom and having those rights
and freedoms deliver them Liberty
equality and Equity there is nothing
better than that and we can do so much
we can be a great country a great nation
a community a diverse community
of the greatest generation on Earth and
I believe that generation gen Z
understands that in this moment it is
historic it really truly is I'm a
millennial
I'm a millennial
and I I you could say a lot of bad
things about my generation you could say
a lot of good things about my generation
I think as you can about any generation
but more than anything this gen Z
sees it's their Moment In Time
they have met this moment
they didn't choose it
they didn't choose a bunch of [ __ ]
fascists
trying to take power they didn't choose
that
but they sure have met that moment in
history
they sure have made made it clear that
they are going to engage in democracy
and that's the most exciting thing that
comes
from yesterday
second most exciting thing is I think I
think women showed their power because I
believe women are the true leaders
Future Leaders of this country men have
[ __ ] this thing up long enough
absolutely [ __ ] this thing up long
enough
it's enough of the [ __ ] garbage and
the misogyny and the
Women are Smarter they're better at
governing it's just a thing it's a
[ __ ] thing I know it might I'm gonna
get flat for this but women are so much
better at governing they are way better
at it
way better at it you can just you can
see it when when children have problems
in a group a man ah make a problem worse
woman she'll clean that problem up quick
fast and in a hurry
and I know that's just a generalization
but it's true
so I am so excited that young people and
women
are becoming the leaders of this country
and not just the leaders in government
but the leaders in our democracy
engaging
it has an effect we are the boss we're
the boss
we're the ones who get to tell them what
the [ __ ] to do they don't have they
don't get to tell us what the [ __ ] to do
and we show them that yesterday
and I'm so glad
that you got out and you voted let's do
this we got to go to the [ __ ] list
Roundup because I got a ton of video I
want to show you let's see if we can get
Gabe Sanchez in here but let's do this
let's start the countdown let's surf the
Tweety tweets and the trendy trends
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show you have
reached the part of the Tony Michaels
podcast where we round up all the Tweety
tweets and trendy trends of the day we
surf Twitter as long as Twitter's still
around have you noticed
that the little check marks the little
the little uh blue checks there's two of
them have you noticed this on some
accounts this is [ __ ] stupid
have you noticed this
this is [ __ ] ridiculous
I don't mean to keep harping on Elon
Musk and Twitter but God damn
he [ __ ] the bed more than Republicans
did yesterday he apparently had to sell
like four [ __ ] billion dollars worth
of Tesla stock to keep this [ __ ]
going
when is he gonna auction it off that's
the question I want when are these
investors going to go to him and say
nope you're done auctioned off
cut cut and run cut on the losses
[ __ ] get the hell out of that
sumbitch
I mean Twitter's not gonna go anywhere
the user base is humongous it's one of
the biggest user bases in the world
it's just a matter just a matter of how
much money Elon Musk is gonna [ __ ]
bleed out here
I mean I hope he hangs on to it for a
long time really [ __ ] Stick it to him
yeah why not it'll make him go from the
richest man in the world to you know
like third richest
but this this check mark thing
this check mark thing come on
I mean really you're gonna give two
check marks now I don't know why in the
[ __ ] and I asked Gabe Sanchez this
morning and maybe maybe when he gets
here and I don't see him yet but when he
gets here on air
um I'll ask him why didn't they just do
a v
I I don't know why why why this whole
[ __ ] blue check thing
you know what I mean so I I mean I'm not
I'm not against I'm not against the
whole paying eight dollars to have
Twitter blue
I mean it's like 4.99 now and or was now
it's like 7.99 so it's like three
dollars more
I mean that's not gonna make a [ __ ]
hella beans worth the difference on Elon
musk's you know it the bottom line
but why in the [ __ ] didn't they just put
like a V
so the counts could have a different
marking and and verified it you know
blue Check accounts that are quote
unquote official could have the blue
check and then people who wanted to
verify with Twitter blue would have a v
verified for Twitter blue why didn't
they do that
but now they got two [ __ ] check marks
here let me show you know let's see if I
can find one I think minus touch has the
uh
um their account there's some that do
some that don't so it's obvious that
it's like a slow rollout or some [ __ ]
yeah let's see I think there's no I
don't know
maybe not let's see maybe we can find it
in the uh what the [ __ ]
yeah maybe it's just on mobile it may
just be on mobile at this point
I don't know we have to ask Gabe Sanchez
when he gets here I'm not I'm not seeing
that but but this morning there were
several accounts that have the blue
check and then underneath it has like a
a Halo check mark
our silhouette excuse me check mark with
with official account next to it
so in other words they just added
another check mark to say that it's
official when they already had it
official I don't understand this [ __ ]
just make a V for verified Twitter blue
just do that why are you making this so
com why are they [ __ ] making this so
complicated they should have said hey
you know that Twitter blue thing that we
had oh here's Gabe Sanchez maybe he can
answer some of these [ __ ] questions
that I got here Gabe why didn't why
didn't they just put a v
oh are you okay we're talking about
Twitter right now yeah well I mean I'm
all right so this is this conversation
out of the way yeah well I I don't know
if anyone knows this but they've already
killed
the double verification
wait wait wait wait this morning they
were adding it yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
already done
I took a screenshot of one of them so
they're all down look look look at my
tweet what I said
yeah all right is that is that why
you're late is that what you're tweeting
is that what I was doing my research
tell me God damn okay so uh let's see
this is the is it the top one the pinned
one yeah yeah yeah okay okay so here is
here's here's the Tweet uh you said Elon
has Twitter employees work 12 to 14
hours a day to jam through a
non-solution for his verification
problem because really it's not a the
thing the solution that they're doing
isn't going to solve the problem that
they say they have
um
and then you go on to say it was live
for a few hours and then they killed it
what a wasteful idiot I mean really
honestly how many how many millions is
he gonna bleed okay so this is um Esther
Crawford she's an employee of Twitter
right right so she is the one if people
remember uh there was a photo that went
around of an employee that was on the
floor sleeping in his sister in the gray
sleeping bag and it looked like against
the wall with a bunch of chairs around
her right exactly and they're like when
you're trying to get an answer from your
manager right and then you're at Twitter
right
she was the one that like I think if I
remember correctly she proudly shared
that online or was in the comments being
like oh you do what you got to do I mean
someone took a picture of her and then
she put it on her account I believe
that's how I forget I forget if she
posted or if she commented but basically
this is her this is her and she was
probably like you do what you got to do
you know when you love what you love all
that [ __ ] right right which whatever
I mean truth is known if you want to
give your entire life to eat a dumb [ __ ]
like Elon you know right and I can tell
you I um
I've gone through this type of stuff
before I've gone through late hours in
the in the midnight rush and you're
trying to get a release out in time and
there's a bug and you got to fix it and
you're late and something crashes like
I've been through that where where you
are literally there all night trying to
fix something you know in preparation
for the morning launch
and that's why I comment so much on this
stuff especially when I'm like you don't
do it the day before a major event like
he was planning to do on the seventh you
don't do it on a Friday when everyone's
gone for the weekend there are certain
rules that you that you keep in mind
when you're trying to launch a product
another one don't let Trump endorse
candidates that's another right that
would be a third law too you know okay
if there's if there's like I'm just
gonna throw that in yeah yeah those are
the like I wonder why Elon I wonder why
Elon was waiting for the midterms to see
if he's gonna let Trump back on he's
like well maybe we should wait to see
how poppy this [ __ ] so you know
maybe I give him too much credit I know
right so what happened here is this
employee talks about you know she's a
lot of folks have asked about you know
how you'll be able to distinguish
between the Twitter blue subscribers
with blue check marks and accounts that
are verified as official being like
celebrities companies Brands things like
that because because basically you know
to not just go back too much yeah yeah
but they're changing the blue check from
the verified as official to just being
someone who plays a Elon eight bucks
right I mean that's I mean basically
that blue check is now going to indicate
and it's no ID verification it's
literally just I made a payment just a
payment a payment and this is a blue
check mark to say this person paid eight
dollars now again
it's tied to a payment transaction but
anyone you could literally use a debit
card if you wanted to put the
transaction I couldn't use like a
prepaid like exactly so you wouldn't be
able to there's many ways you could get
around this whole like bot problem that
Elon wants to [ __ ] and moan about but
this is the problem that they're
creating they're recreating the original
problem and I had some people last night
because I was like look what they're
doing is they're saying all right
officially yeah here's here's the
picture here's the this was like the the
uh roll out of this right so you have
Twitter here with the blue check and
then down below the handle you have this
another check with official next to it
so you're like double dipping here I
don't understand so if people if people
know like especially people who are
political candidates and they're running
they're either officially they they won
that that seat and they sit there as the
representative or Senator or you know
whatever or they are a candidate running
for that seat down the ballot
the visual real estate that you see here
is how it would be for a candidate that
was running for political office or sits
in political office is you've got the
name with the badge the handle and then
it says like you know whatever Colorado
District whatever let's say whatever
whatever ballot they're on or whatever
office they hold so this is a solution
that is one it's not creative or
Innovative it doesn't really fix the
problem here because what you're doing
is you're taking existing visual real
estate on here and they're just saying
great if they truly are the official
account then we will put down and reuse
it as that space which then gets
confusing because the other thing is
like some people will have official but
then how are political candidates or
people who are in in political office
going to be distinguished now are they
adding another one I mean there's so
many there's so many other different
there's a lot of things of official
right there's a lot of other things in
there that have been used for that area
it to be like oh [ __ ] that's the real
person right but now they're adding
official so there's like oh is it
official comma something is it going to
be official that and then is that right
this looks stupid right right
like this not even just like it makes no
sense to take up the real estate this
looks dumb right because you got okay
here's the blue check that you paid for
and then oh by the way here's your other
check that we have to give you to make
sure that people are are verifying that
it's in the official account because it
isn't this verified thing and the blue
check the way it used to be isn't to say
you know one account's better than the
other what it's actually designed to do
is inside that Community to say hey this
account is official there's something
significant about it now regardless of
when you got your blue check or why you
got your blue check there's something
significant right and they've changed
those verification uh standards
throughout the years which has made it
more and more complicated to get a blue
check yeah
um but this really seems like to me and
I I actually I think I messaged you this
yesterday I'm like how many days is this
gonna take so apparently one yeah less
than one literally hours
and they started to roll out because
this morning there was you could see
some accounts had it some accounts did
not but here's the thing is that why in
the [ __ ] I I just like this morning
looking at this for more than I don't
know three seconds and here is here's uh
Esther says a lot of folks have asked
about I'm like maybe you should have
thought through like more than just like
30 more seconds maybe 40 and maybe it
took you two and a half more minutes to
take this through to figure out why are
you duplicating the blue check when you
could just say Twitter blue which is a
service that they have we are raising
the price three dollars because we're
giving additional benefits and one of
those benefits is we're gonna give you a
v that shows that you're a verified blue
Twitter blue user there there are
countless solutions that you could apply
you can even put like a dollar sign in
eight dollars
whatever yeah if you if you wanted to
add a new badge or a different color
badge because here's the thing like like
next to the like next to them yeah I
mean if you want it well you wouldn't
need to like if they're right but like
right like right here right next to you
you get because there's some social
media platforms that have more than one
badge yeah there are there are different
places online networks that'll have oh
there's multiple badges now you could
add a different color badge if you're
just like I paid for this badge versus I
am really this person badge right I mean
so you mean like like um so the blue
check would be the official count and
then maybe like a a green check yeah you
could do it you paid money you paid
green right exactly you could have it
and that's just one solution right there
are countless Solutions instead of
stacking icons and stacking text because
that's what this is doing before it was
like ah the name the handle and then it
was like oh this person's in this
political office now it's like uh you
know it's icon is this him killing it in
real time this is him killing it this is
in response to it are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] me this is him responding to
another person that I follow who does
like tech reviews uh Marquis and uh he
was like hey I got it
again he's tweeting policy see he is
trumping Twitter
like Trump would do this during his
administration and the fact that this is
like there's there's a there is a uh a
mentality or a mindset in Tech in San
Francisco in Silicon Valley where it's
like move fast and break things now that
that works within uh the realm of I'm a
small company and I just gotta [ __ ]
hack [ __ ] away and see what works and I
can test I can test and invalidate ideas
and then we can go for them we can try
to make money but when you're a global
company and you're pushing out code and
you're saying great I got this new
feature and then you within moments you
know hours or whatever you swipe that
[ __ ] away because one you didn't you did
not actually think it through you did
not look at the problem because Elon
Musk came in and he was like I've got
the solution the answer to the bot
problem to the verification problem is
we need to do x y z right we need to add
a blue check mark we need raises a price
it's going to be 20. it's going to be
eight people pay more they verify who
they are but again you can use prepaid
debit cards you don't actually have to
prove who you are there is no ID
verification in this process right now
the actual verification process is kind
of a gray area you have to provide links
or maybe you have a rep who talks on
your behalf to prove that you're
actually this person or what have you so
In This Moment people need to realize
that they are literally just recreating
I had some people that were like oh this
doesn't recreate and I'm like no it
literally recreates the problem because
what is happening it's the same [ __ ]
right and also it's like I don't want to
like I
I literally all they're doing is just
changing the price of Twitter blue that
that is literally all they're doing
right I mean yeah they're adding maybe a
few benefits but they're just all
they're doing is just changing the price
that's all they're doing and and for me
like so my background I'm a product
designer I've built products I've
launched products I've done that for
over 11 years this is my [ __ ] this is
what I do okay now when I see all of
these things line up and I say and I've
said it publicly on Twitter I was like
this is a shitty idea you don't do this
you don't do this I've talked about on
the show then you've got this thing
where they're like all right great we're
gonna double verify people on this app
which is like insane to think about that
you'd have to even do that there should
be already if you already have that
verification system that you verified
how many how many verified users are
there how many blue checks are there
400 400 000 people okay already they've
already done the work of 400 000
verifications right right to give blue
checks right and those people aren't
even here's the thing those blue check
marks I know people that have blue check
marks that get them taken away and
they're given no explanation and so
there's a whole thing there which is
like even the 400 000 people that they
would assume would pay for it to keep
their uh blue badge right again we've
done the math doing that right by giving
them another badge now they're saying
well you don't have to pay eight bucks
right it's a whole it doesn't make any
sense stupid the process is even more
convoluted and confusing it doesn't need
to be this way but again Elon came in
and was like I'm a genius and I know
exactly what I need to do and look I'm
not claiming to know the answer but I am
telling you that there are other
solutions to this without recreating the
original problem and almost what he did
it almost feels like there was like a
bunch of people in red hats that like
had a virtual rally and they're like pay
eight dollars pay eight dollars pay
eight dollars and he's like yeah that's
a good idea and then we did that and
then it [ __ ] flopped right there was
there was another example of that
somewhere in history I'm not sure maybe
recent history we're a bunch of [ __ ]
in-cell [ __ ] got together and
decided it was a good idea to put some
buffoon in charge or something yeah yeah
yeah I mean based on the what happened
last night we'll see but the last thing
I will say about this Twitter situation
is
his response where he's like I killed it
you know and then he was like uh uh you
know blue blue check will be the the app
the the equal like the level like the
the equal leveler in this community
right which is what it already was so
they're now going back to the original
prop or the the original like solution
to this issue right blue check would be
a great level which is like
my biggest my biggest pet peeve is that
Elon Musk came into the company was
already planning to lay off 50 at least
50 of the company
he came in with some ideas to say this
is how we're going to fix it this is how
we're going to make money this is how
we're not going to burn through so much
stupid ideas by the way but yeah yeah
his idea was we're burning about 4
million probably more we talked about
that probably I just got to be double
that right it's got to be sold four you
just won four billion hours and exactly
it's got to be at least one and a half
to two x more than what he's claiming so
it's probably six to eight million uh
right
when you have a bunch of advertisers I'm
not against Elon burning cash by the way
you do what you do you pay 44 billion
for a company that you overvalued
because you got caught in a joke that
you were trying to own the lips for when
you actually got owned hey man [ __ ]
go for it great so keep going buddy just
keep so so now we have this issue where
he comes in he declares he has a
solution and how to make money he
implements these ideas I'm sure people
at the company were like we've already
thought about that this is literally
things that we thought about ages ago
and we killed it and then he was like no
we got to do it we got to do it and so
people work 12 to 14 hours they're
[ __ ] killing themselves to sleep on
the floor and work all day and work all
night to then
to then not know their own situation and
Status at the company be like I don't
know coming this Friday if which is last
week if if I will still have a job at
this company so I'm killing myself
working day and night right to do this
and I find out on Friday oh I don't have
a job and then on Saturday I get an
email that says hey we made a mistake
would you want to come back and work at
the company and that's what he did and
then they were like okay we're not going
to verify people and do this whole
rollout on the seventh the day before
the midterms we're going to do it after
and then they start rolling it out today
and they go oops we [ __ ] up it
actually isn't the way to do this and
now we're going to take it away from
everyone this whole thing has been a
[ __ ] and for everyone who's like
you launched a genius and he knows
exactly what he's doing [ __ ] because
I can tell you each of those times is
him just throwing [ __ ] at the wall and
being like this will work and it doesn't
work well let me let me show you
um an example of uh Elon supporter I'm
sure
I'm sure this one loves Elon I'm sure
this was in Arizona did you hear
Yesterday in Arizona Kerry Lake
um was losing her mind because they had
to count ballots by hand and they wanted
to extend the polling hours by three
hours oh how so convenient for the group
that they know is going to lose or is
losing they're like oh can we get
Charlie just loses his [ __ ] mind
yesterday though but also Kerry Lake
yesterday she was doing a little press
tour and she was like I am going to be
your worst enemy for the next eight
years I'm gonna make why would he treat
it why would any candidate ever say into
a microphone while they're running I'm
gonna be your worst [ __ ] nightmare
like why I mean honestly I know she was
directing a journalist but why would
people in Arizona be like Jesus Christ
are you kidding me so we're gonna have
to live through this garbage for the
next eight years why would we elect you
so here is here is um someone who went
to the the polling station where the
machine stopped working
um
the machines weren't working and they
have I don't know like backup plans
because sometimes these machines are you
know they have glitches and there's
another box that you a secure box that
you put your ballon in to be hand
counted that's why that's why some of
these results are are lagging out of
Arizona because there were some of these
machines that weren't working so they
had to I don't know hand count them
that's how it [ __ ] right Works in
elections but here listen to her explain
this
and then we'll talk about it
we are at this location and their voting
machines are not working properly
they don't count the ballots you go in
to register they give you a ballot which
takes like 20 minutes which is
ridiculous you go in you place you do
your voting you go in you give it into
the machine and it won't take it it says
misread ballot every single person in
there is getting them this red ballot so
now you're all just saying drop them
into the box and hand count it
supposedly oh my gosh my husband's done
two ballots he had to do a canceled
ballot the second ballot he went in to
vote same thing so every person in that
line now that's standing there is not
going to get counted properly that we
don't know
hold on hold on Karen Karen here Karen
lady this lady oh my God all right so
yeah there is okay guys it's called
redundancy there's a backup plan or a
contingency plan in terms of how to
actually count this it's almost like we
would go back to how we originally
counted ballots before a machine did
yeah but don't don't aren't they the
ones that hate the machines anyways
don't you think they're excited to put a
[ __ ] yeah to put a ballot in a box
that has to be hand counted don't you
think right I mean I don't know whatever
he says you can't trust the machines
right yeah I mean Mike Lindell is the
one who said I'm gonna Sue all the
machines I'm gonna you know I mean look
this [ __ ] doesn't make any sense it
doesn't make you here's the first thing
here's the first thing okay what she's
talking about is this does not prevent
you from casting your ballot right
because that's what she's claiming well
right I know but but but she's not
voting on a machine okay
um at our polling places in Missouri we
have a paper ballot and you mark the
ballot and then you feed the ballot into
the machine and it tabulates that that
ballot with account right now that's not
the official count that's just the
tabulation that the machine gives them
right that's why they they don't just
take the [ __ ] date and like ah that
must be what it is they have to verify
it yeah [ __ ] Rubes how do you think
they verify it they take the ballots out
of the secure counting box and they
[ __ ] count them so what so what she's
saying is because the machine wouldn't
suck in the ballot and verify it she's
saying they're cheating her like no
because the machine won't verify it
they're saying hey we want you to stick
it in this box because it's not
verifying your vote so we can't trust
that machine they're doing what you're
saying you want them to do yeah why
can't these [ __ ] I mean it's not
surprising coming from this what looks
like
a person who would lose their mind if
they got the wrong you know mocha frecka
tall latte or whatever the hell it is I
don't know I don't order that kind of
[ __ ] I just get coffee black coffee
that's what I want I want nothing in it
I want sugar no cream just coffee but it
looks like this person would lose her
mind and start throwing cups of coffee
yeah I mean this is clearly the same
person that would also freak out if
you're like hey man this is a private
business and we ask that you wear a mask
right 100 this would be the type of
woman that would freak out on someone
who's like look I didn't make the I
didn't make this
decision right I work for an employee a
private company and you have to follow
the rules and look I'm not gonna follow
the rules
rules and women this is like let me you
know what
what speak to the elections County Clerk
official
and they're like what the [ __ ] well you
know what's even better about this is
when she's bitching about standing in
line for 20 minutes like you [ __ ] I
stood in line for 30 minutes and my mine
is typical I usually I like to go on
Election Day just because I'm like I
like to I like to go out and I do feel
that energy and like I that's what I
wrote on Election Day and that's how I
do it the nice thing is here's thing we
have an uh in in La
um I don't know if it's all around
California or just in certain counties
or certain cities but
we have you can do a a test ballot on
your phone so you go to LA county and
you go to the I forgot what the link is
but you go there what do you mean test
ballot so you can go on your phone and
you can start picking the the choices
right here I wanna because you actually
vote on a machine like you're yeah so we
have we have a vote you're not voting on
paper you're not voting on paper you're
voting on it yeah yeah since 2018 we've
had these electronic machines I mean I
moved here in 2018 so it's I think that
was the first year but yeah we've had it
for the last three elections now right
these three major elections
um and so you get a test ballot and you
go onto your phone you go to this URL
you can scan a QR code you go to the URL
and you go through a test spell in a
test ballot allows you to pre-select
your answers so if you're waiting in
line like I waited 30 minutes yesterday
because it was super busy I went during
lunch time which is a typical rush
there's three rushes obviously the
morning before work during lunch and
after work and I was in line and they're
like hey if you guys want to cut down on
time that way you're not going through
and actually uh having to go through the
voting and all the pages
when you get up there you can do it on
your phone and then you can either use
that as like great I have a test I got
the answers you know kind of a little
cheat sheet for yourself but you can say
oh don't no don't no cheating
[ __ ] so on the phone on the
phone you've got all your selections and
you say okay I'm done and you get a QR
code and then you go to the machine and
so you can scan it and double check it
and it goes through so yeah I had I had
my so you basically have your ballot
ready and done before you exactly and I
had my booklet so much faster exactly so
while I was in line I had my booklet
boom I did it on my phone I double
checked my answers how I had it on the
booklet I scanned it I double checked to
make sure the answers that I had on the
actual ballot were the same as what I
had on the phone
you just feed it in it takes the votes
it feeds it out and then it says all
right if you're ready to cast your
ballot feed it in and then you have to
select one more time to be like yes I
want to cast my Ballot or no actually
send it back out because there's an
issue and then you cast the ballot and
it's in Missouri you get it you gotta
get the pen and you got to fill in the
the oval and then feed it and it's yeah
I want to point out something and of
course when you have fake Gabe in the
comments as always yeah I mean he says
it sounds like an issue hey hey dummy we
just said it was an issue and they had
they had a plan
to make sure that people's balance were
counted what they're doing in this clip
is they're making something that is not
what it is like you people always do you
always take a little Marshal of the fact
that oh yeah machine's having trouble
but we put it in a secure box so we can
hand count and make sure those ballots
are counted yeah you which is what you
people said that you want to have happen
because the machines are the ones that
are cheating it's the Democrats with the
algorithms and the isms and the
internets and the interwebs and those
cyber guys or I don't know what Mike
Lindell says I don't know he needs for a
guy who makes [ __ ] pillows the guy
doesn't take enough [ __ ] naps he
needs to take a [ __ ] his for sure and
I also I saw someone say that that it
sounds complicated it actually is very
it's a seamless process I'm literally on
my phone and it's like I'm picking a
menu uh menu you're ordering like you're
ordering off a menu to right it's like
hey I want to order these tacos for
tonight you know right well you know
this is this is another this is another
good point
um is that technology
is great and we have a lot of it all
around us the one place that it didn't
show up was these polls and that's why
gen Z was under counted in the polls
yeah and we've said that on the show
before we talked about how these people
were like the polls say this
you need to update the way in which you
communicate to a younger generation you
need to find a way not only I will say
this not only does the Democratic party
need to improve the way in which they
they contact and get in touch with a
younger demographic right
it's just something and I was watching a
few different uh programs last night
kind of going between and I think it was
CBS
and they were talking about
uh she was like oh I forget who it was
but she was like oh my grandchildren or
like my nieces and nephews they're
younger and they're all streaming it you
know they're streaming on their phone we
can't be like can't be sent out mailers
which I have my own issue with mailers
that go out because most of them just
end up in a bin in like my lobby area
because people just pull them out and
they just like I don't want this and
they throw them in but like we need to
find ways to better contact and
communicate with those who are voting
especially such a huge population that
is so active like gen Z and gen Z is the
reason and women are the reason why uh a
lot of these a lot of these uh things
that were on the ballot a lot of these
candidates but also you know oh should
women have a right to their own body
yeah they should right and you have to
remember that those are some of the
people that were able to push those
things forward
um even though the minority of
Republicans who are in power in DC in
the house or the Senate are trying to
make a national Banner trying to
restrict things they're super happy that
the Supreme Court overturned Roe v Wade
and now that it is back on the state
level those people are getting pissed
because gen Z and women and others who
actually believe in bodily autonomy are
speaking up and saying like Okay if it
is our choice like you say it's supposed
to be then [ __ ] you we actually believe
in this and you guys don't have a say in
it and now it's getting you know added
to state constitutions which again
Republicans don't like because that's
not what they wanted or at least the
people in power and Republican party not
what they wanted and it's turning around
and biting them in the ass
fake Gabe has another comment here it's
it's it's great to have you fake Gabe he
says it it demonstrates incompetence how
does it demonstrate incompetence when
the lady told you in the clip that her
husband was allowed to cast two ballots
yeah and after he couldn't get the
machine to take his one ballot they were
able to put the ballot to be hand
counted in a secure box doesn't seem in
common to me and oh by the way do you
know what party the [ __ ] Republicans
are that what party is the governor of
Arizona currently you stupid [ __ ] who is
it who is it fake Gabe what party what
party is in charge in Arizona you stupid
bastard you really you really just do
not have a clue maybe you should go
Google before you start posting your
[ __ ] stupid Trump carry Lake copy
machine in the goddamn Commons you look
like a [ __ ] thank you by the way I'm
I'm glad to have your stupidity and I
just want to point something out for
fake Gabe and other people who say oh
it's taking too long it's not happening
on Wednesday morning what the [ __ ] okay
two things one there is an increase in
population of people voting right people
are more active especially because these
hot button topics are on the ballot and
these people are saying no I I don't
want you to control myself well again
Gabe but we're trying to cheat we're
shutting down machines right we gotta we
gotta make sure
but it is it is important to remember
we're cheating it's all a conspiracy
against you and we're all involved even
me the Tony Michaels I'm the head of all
of it man I'm the head of all of it we
are right right hand right-hand men to
George Soros
the thing I want to point out to fake
Avery and other people is when you
complain about how long it's taking for
the results to come back you need to
remember
guys I'm sorry to spoil this for you you
need to remember who controls those
legislations that were passed or the
legislators that were passing those
things to say like you can't count those
ballots until this this time after the
polls close
here right Pennsylvania you've got
various other states that actually have
to wait and they were passed by
republican-led legislators so
don't get don't get all mad at Democrats
or like oh this like Charlie Kirk this
is voter suppression this is this is
this is this no it's literally following
the rule of law that your party put in
place as a means
of trying to suppress Democratic vote
because those were mail-in those
revisional those were absentee let's
let's do this because I really want to
get to some of these crying clips
because they're really crying in these
clips that they didn't have a red wave
so let's let's do like a a lightning
round on some of these clips this is the
um uh I think it's the lieutenant
governor of Georgia talking about how he
wants to [ __ ] bounce Trump listen
okay we're not does that change if the
balance of power in the Senate depends
on this race so my actual answer was I
didn't get uh I didn't respect Herschel
Walker yet and he had not earned my vote
and I was not going to vote for Raphael
Warnock so we still have four more weeks
but you know I think a lot of
Republicans like me are waking up this
morning going what could have been what
could have been if we would have picked
a better candidate that could have won
with a margin like Brian can that would
have been able to put real leadership on
display real ideas in the hearts and
minds of Georgians and get the state
back to being fully read and Brian Kemp
had this resounding Victory despite the
fact that Trump you know had once
predicted he was going to go down in
flames at The Ballot Box he defeated his
Trump back opponent in that primary and
then of course he had a big victory last
night what message does that send do you
think I think it sends a message to the
country along with some other states
that this is truly a pivot point for the
Republican party this is a time that
Donald Trump is no doubt in the rearview
mirror and it's time to move on with the
party it's time to move on with
candidate quality it turns out Mitch
McConnell knew what he was talking about
about Camp ooh [ __ ] shots across the
bow and fake Gabe's gonna be like you
didn't play the whole clip okay yeah
okay um here's another one yeah it's
gonna be the same thing all these people
are now saying ooh the Teflon Don
doesn't have the touch he had anymore
because all these [ __ ] hand-picked
candidates either lost or were losing
last night like all of them began to go
they were going down in [ __ ] flames
and I think this is the beginning of the
Republican Party being like all right
that nope nope no no no no we can't do
that anymore I actually don't agree with
you I don't agree with you I'll tell you
what okay let's watch this all right
shifted and right now Zelda is probably
within five points it might be at a
reach for them there's no been
concession there you see there's some
unhappiness but I don't know about you
guys I'm shocked there was a no Red Wave
if you think about inflation a 40-year
high crime that were since the 1980s the
unpopular president with an agenda
that's more green oriented than people
oriented they just can't figure it out
so there's that one um let's see some
more let's see uh well they also I mean
on another on another Fox program last
night they see there they keep saying
they're like it's the worst since the
1980s it's the worst since the 1990s
they keep changing because they're not
actually bringing real news right to to
these to any election that are happening
well they're trying to find who's to
blame listen to this right that said
this should have been the red wave that
even Democratic pundits on other
networks were saying was absolutely
going to happen so is the Republican
brand now broken in some level Carly
where now just now they can govern
okay so again it's just more the same
they're just crying in their their
[ __ ] little a little oh here here we
go here's the here's here's here's um
the great take this is the great take on
why ons lost
um Gabe I don't know if you know why Oz
lost but let's listen to Fox News why Oz
lost with voters when it comes to the
state of Pennsylvania why did Dr Oz Lose
well it looks like according to uh the
exit polling it's because fetterman won
[Applause]
oh my God oh my God I can't even this is
great this is the greatest [ __ ] clip
Vault why Gabe why did Dr Oz Lose it's
probably because his opponent John
vetterman Won it's like honestly
honestly it sounds like I sent you
another clip which I think is part of it
it's a back and forth of what they said
and what what they said last night but
that type of answer reminds me of like a
John Madden like play-by-play well look
uh they need to run up the field and
score touchdown in order to win and uh
that'll be the game yeah thank you John
that's we understand that that's exactly
the way they're gonna get a first down
is they got to get 10 yards they gotta
go 10 yards here to get a first down
like yeah we get we get the rules we
know how it works okay here's here's um
here's the clip you sent me the
Democrats probably should say you know
what we put too much emphasis on
abortion and the threat to democracy
yeah and not enough emphasis
and democracy were the two of the
biggest issues with voters the Democrats
okay this is more the same and we've
been saying this [ __ ] here on this show
like we have been saying forever hey
don't get scared don't believe the polls
it's all a bunch of [ __ ] just do the
work do the work engage and go out and
use your [ __ ] voice with your ballot
right and just do what democracies do
that's what you got to do here and and
you've listened you listened
um here here's another here's another
great clip
um here's this one this is from November
1st
um now this is um on the first clip is
from Joy reads
um program on MSNBC and then Laura
Ingraham uh commentary yeah this is from
the first of November so this is just
over a week ago let's listen it's more
than half the polls conducted in October
have been been conducted by Republican
firms and that means that basically we
can't trust the data on real clear
politics or 538 any longer because it's
essentially a republican propaganda now
Simon has been saying this on Twitter
for a long time the same thing we've
been saying that hey don't listen to the
polls it's a bunch of [ __ ] they were
off in Kansas they were off in New
York's 19th they were off in Alaska
they're not accurate they're wrong and
we've been saying that since that
happened since the moment it happened in
Kansas and Simon's been talking about
this and showing this um with the early
voting tabulations like showing that hey
showing the evidence that hey the
[ __ ] polls are wrong and that's when
the media really went hey maybe the
polls are wrong but listen to Laura
Ingram follow up here
oh Simon come on joining us Now to
respond is the president and co-founder
of RealClearPolitics Tom Bevin Tom your
reaction to this assault on the Real
Clear Politics assault and averages as
it's all Republican propaganda should be
interesting tonight yeah a couple of
points to make number one
um it's actually been the Republican
firms like Trafalgar and others who've
been more accurate over the last three
Cycles than uh most polling firms and
it's been nope none of that's true none
of that here's here's something else
remember so when you've got places like
538 which you know was started by Nate
silver and everyone and early on
he was very accurate but those numbers
have begun to shift he's been right in
one election in his life all right
and he's still living off the residual
in 2008 and wasn't it 2012 as well well
right but I mean you're living off a lot
of residuals
you're talking 14 years ago right right
I mean I mean if you're going if you're
going 50 for 50 you know it's a pretty
big like oh boy you know so the the only
reason when's the last time he was right
when's the last time well yeah I'm
saying like those are the last two
elections but right but what I'm saying
is and we talked about this before is
the polling is Antiquated it's it's not
gonna get an accurate number the way
they do the polling rather they try to
[ __ ] juice it or not from the left or
the right because that was one thing he
tweeted the other day Nate silver he
said well it really is something that
says something when the Democrats aren't
giving us Juiced polls like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about so you want
fake numbers literally all Nate silver
is is he just organizes numbers that's
it he doesn't know [ __ ] about [ __ ] he
doesn't know [ __ ] about candidates he
doesn't know [ __ ] about districts he
doesn't know [ __ ] about these races he
didn't know [ __ ] about who's voting he
only organizes numbers that are given to
him that is it he's a he's a cute cute
guy who knows math he's not that cute by
the way but but also the thing that
people need to and if people don't know
here if people don't know how 538 get
does or like how Nate silver does the
actual math on this
it's it's not uh it's not crazy like oh
this is like some brand new idea what so
in in statistics or in in math you're
running regressions on on numbers right
and you're basically running these these
models over and over again and you're
taking a CBS poll an NBC poll and a CNN
poll an MSNBC poll and you're taking
them all together you're aggregating and
you're running again and again and again
so that the margin of air is so so
minute it's so small that your
predictions won't be off by uh more than
like thousands of votes right like
you're running them again and again and
you're testing all the time as these
polls come out now however
in this moment if you're getting a lot
of right leaning pulls right a lot of
right-leaning polls that say this
candidate's going to win it's going to
be a blowout here and a red wave a red
wave here
what happens to an average that you've
aggregated and you have run continuous
regressions on is that you're going to
find that that end result is going to be
heavily favored into a right uh
Republican red ending a result so if you
have more red in your sample and you're
running regressions on it you're going
to find that the end result is going to
be more red in its determination of the
results right in the aggregate which
yeah you know rather it helped or hurt I
don't know but it definitely did not
help the Red Wave
um but I know what I know what did
affect a red wave and here is Fox News
and
they they always run right into the
point but they never know it let's
listen so is this the candidate quality
question that was that was discussed and
you know who who where does the blame
lie for that yeah who who would who
would be the guy that you would blame
for picking these candidates look that
is why [ __ ] Mitch McConnell weeks ago
weeks ago was basically saying hey we're
not going to win this and I'm not going
to be held responsible it's the [ __ ]
Cheeto dust queuing on her that's
responsible for this
um do you know who this is
the floor oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
she was really confident yesterday right
I think she lost her Race by the way
um but she posted this yesterday she
said today's forecast and she you know
obviously has a red wave I don't know if
this from like a Kool-Aid commercial or
where this is from uh I think they
somebody just like you know a little
little uh color dropper and then said
great I want to replace color and make
it yeah so just it's just it it was
originally you know because naturally
waves are blue right they said oh look
we're gonna replace it to look like it's
a goddamn shining well um Mad Max says
here
is that her period I don't know exactly
what that means I maybe maybe it has
something to do with tampons but here's
here's what I'll tell you here's what
I'll tell you I treated this oh I quote
tweeted I said
I would say delete this but [ __ ] it
leave this [ __ ] up so we can all point
and laugh at you hashtag red trickle
because and she hasn't deleted it yet I
can't I can't believe I can't believe
they haven't deleted these [ __ ]
things this is well they're not going to
right because they they believe uh that
they are
they are the winner now others in the
party have been like let's call what it
is guys this was a devastating loss we
lost Lindsey Graham said that Lindsey
Graham yeah right Lindsey Graham also I
was watching uh I forgot what program it
was might have been ABC or might have
been CBS but he went on and he said look
I was in charge of Guam and I got that
vote he was like
he he was like I don't know like you
know he was asked about Ron DeSantis
versus Trump wait wait wait wait wait I
saw this he was running the Victory lap
for for Guam right and so this is what
happened they asked me like oh you know
is the result or the outcome you know
it's not as expected he's like yeah well
you know like he also admitted he's like
we've got our own problems so that was
one thing that he said in there he
admitted something long ago that someone
they keep reposting his tweeting it says
something about a week take if we get
Trump we're gonna destroy ourselves or
something like that I don't know it's
almost like he said something smart for
once right so last night they're asking
him about hey look the turnout and the
outcome of these results in these
elections weren't it's not the red wave
that you guys all thought it was he goes
yeah you know it's not as we expected uh
it we've got our own issues
um and then they asked him about Ron
DeSantis versus Trump and if Trump going
on the campaign Trail in the month of
October was a pro or rather he kind of
took a little bit of a Hiatus he didn't
have as many rallies but then up until
the last point it was like rally rally
rally and it was a lot about a him him
Trump me me I'm the victim and the
question was you mean you mean at the
rallies where he's supposed to be
stumping for the candidate he was
talking about himself I wonder what
could went wrong with these races yeah
it's almost like talking about yourself
and not the candidate you know like I'm
trying to think of all the races like JD
Vance obviously won that was one that he
got in his pocket but like Herschel
Walker struggling Brian Kemp was like I
don't want anything to [ __ ] do with
you I definitely don't want anything to
do with herself and it turns out that
strategy ended up helping him because
here's the thing they also saw that 70
000 people who voted for Brian Kemp
looked at Herschel Walker and said nah
like it's insane they either didn't vote
or they voted for the end well I think
that's I well I think that's what what
they did is they did not Mark that
ballot
um and
you sent me this clip this is the clip
that I was talking about in the first
half hour this is something else this is
this really does give you an example of
how stupid Trump supporters really are
and the reason why if you are such a
trump sick event like fake game always
the Trump copy machine you are so
[ __ ] dumb that you sick a fan to this
idiot because he thinks you're stupid
like he truly believes his his the
loyalist of the loyalist supporters are
really dumb for supporting him listen to
this [ __ ]
you've endorsed more than 330 candidates
this election cycle tonight win or lose
the results for Republicans
um how much of that will be because of
Donald Trump
well I think if they win I should get
all the credit and if they lose I should
not be blamed at all okay
showing his supporters
because he's he's hedging his bet here
is what he's doing like he always does
he's straddling the fence he knows he's
probably going to lose big time because
people have probably told him hey we're
gonna [ __ ] lose yeah and he's like if
I win where I win because he's gonna say
I want all the credit for JD Vance but I
don't want any other credit it is all on
Dr Oz doctor eyes failed like how in the
[ __ ] do you square those two things in
your mind well I mean when you're sick
of banning for this idiot right
same guy who during covet was like I
don't take responsibility right like I'm
not the one at fault even though I'm the
one who made these decisions and
policies so it makes sense it I mean the
guy is trying literally says it out loud
he's he's like look if they win I take
credit if they lose I can't be blamed
for it and you're like wait that's not
how it works at all you you you either
take full responsibility and say look I
could have done more for these
candidates or I should have shut my
[ __ ] mouth and I could have done more
for them that way right or done Less in
a way but he wants to say if they win I
win if they lose I still win because I I
never I've never seen any of those
people before and he endorsed over 300
candidates now 291 of those candidates
were election Liars
and I think I don't know the end result
I think it was
uh I forget how many yeah and he was
lying on stage he went to Mar-A-Lago and
he's supposed to give an announcement
but all it was is he came out and he
lied about how many he won and how many
lost now this is this is a picture here
last night that I think it's really
important to see this and a lot of
people weren't pointing this out um
it eventually got pointed out but um
this was at midnight and this is in DC
you see it says take back the house this
was Kevin McCarthy's Victory room and
there ain't a [ __ ] in this thing
yeah this was at midnight uh and this
was them still deciding if they were
going to go out and speak right well and
even in um I think
um Herschel Walkers did you hear this
Herschel Walker's campaign only rented
their venue for their for their Victory
party till 12 45 they were kicking
people out
um oh I didn't hear that yeah I saw him
go out and he's like I don't know what's
gonna happen he's like you guys really
hanging in there but that was awesome ah
police officer and I think if if if I
don't win I'd arrest somebody he
literally it is it isn't I mean he still
thinks martians are coming to this
planet so or are in this in this country
actually he's going to protect us from
those martians here's the moment um on
MS NBC which is khaki karnaki
I'm gonna go out backy and smoke a Packy
with khaki karnaki now Steve kornacki is
like you know he's like the uh the Tom
Brady of of election coverage here yeah
but this is the moment where he show
he's in Colorado and he's showing some
races in Colorado watch their reaction
here to when he he gets to the One race
for some House Seats um it's a bigger
story and we can tell as the night goes
on but I want to flag this right now
because this would be a big surprise the
Third District of Colorado Lauren bobert
the Republican you can see more than 70
percent of the vote is in now in
bobert's trailing by four put this in
some perspective Trump won this District
53-45 over Biden so if you're Adam
Frisch the Democrat you want to be
running five points north of Joe Biden's
number
he was well over five points
we're still I mean I think they're still
counting that race yeah 90 like
Associated Press has it at 93 reporting
New York Times is reporting that they
are still leaning in bobert's favor uh I
mean I wouldn't be surprised if a
recount was ordered on this like it's so
like it's 149 40 421 to 145 946. oh
bobert's definitely gonna call foul and
she's gonna say let's recount which is
probably going to be worse for her we
know that right yeah exactly I always do
not work in their favor I mean the Cyber
ninjas literally learned that in real
time right they also know that Joe Biden
won Arizona by more than what they
thought now now defunct the Cyber ninjas
do not exist anymore they literally went
out of business here here is a clip you
see the the screenshot here for New
Hampshire uh Maggie Hassan which was one
of the seats that Republicans said they
were going to take another one is the uh
the the senate seat in Washington
Washington but
um Hassan won easily I mean you can see
it here just easily but watch the clip
here for the race afterwards and I want
to talk about why this race is so
[ __ ] crucial
um and and the big win here is so
[ __ ] important let's listen
I'm gonna look in on One race that is a
Statewide race of national interest for
of reasons the New York attorney
general's race
James is projected to be re-elected at
70 percent whoosh now only 24 was in so
I'm not sure the final numbers on this
but but it was pretty pretty dramatic
right of a difference feeling to be like
yeah okay we're we're good statistically
there is no way that he comes back from
this so the thing is
um if anyone doesn't know Tish James is
actually again the Attorney General the
current attorney general of the state of
New York she's the one that's brought
the civil case against the Trump
organization
um and it's not going anywhere fast this
was this was Trump's big hope he ran
Michael Henry which who the [ __ ] knows
who Michael Henry is but the point is is
that Trump is um in big trouble in New
York with Tish James
um living rent free inside his head and
in his books because we know that the
judges um got a monitor to monitor him
moving around money which is really bad
for him and because they're even trying
that monitor is going to try to
determine how much money he actually has
liquid to pay the state of New York
which is going to be hilarious when we
find out he doesn't have hardly any
liquid money at all that's going to be
the best part about the whole thing is
we're going to see this monitor by him
trying to move around money and giving
tis James the inlet to get the monitor
appointed by the court it's literally
gonna this is literally going to show us
exactly how [ __ ] broke he really is
the same way he did with the special
master and the Declassified of the
documents he did the same stupid [ __ ]
and it's gonna backfire on him um here's
a graphic though from a race that I
really I really want to show you because
this was really it seemed to be a theme
last night and it's got everyone on edge
and and really people are um wondering
about this race
um in the blue column we have everyone
gets a puppy for 50.1 and then diarrhea
Forever at
49.9 this really does feel like our
country right now does it because as
much as I was very confident even as as
the night went on it got better and
better and better as the red Mirage
faded because that it truly is a red
Mirage because these states out east
they have this where they don't count
certain ballots until afterwards and
they have a certain order Republicans
have made it to where there's a certain
order to count ballots
so it looks like early on in election
nights and it's going to be like this
for a while until we can change some of
this nonsense about the election
um but it always looks like Republicans
are going to [ __ ] win even when it's
really close uh and everyone gets really
nervous but as the night ticks on it
gets better and better and better and
this is just an example of that
um because really this is kind of how it
feels in some parts of the country right
like even even in parts of the country
where you would expect more people to
not have their heads all the way up
their ass
um you know 50 49 on the everyone gets a
puppy or diarrhea forever really is a
big theme right for last night the
Democrats pulled it out no yeah and it's
and it really does go to show you how
imagine
the outcome
of these elections if uh there wasn't
gerrymandering redistricting uh you know
they were disproportionately affecting
uh Black and Latino communities by
requiring certain voter laws
intimidating voters with police uh
Vigilantes that are allowed to kind of
monitor in police election polling
stations these are all things that
Republicans have pushed forward
not not you know Pennsylvania not
counting the ballots because of a a date
that you marked on there but it was
literally postmarked before
uh yeah someone brought up that this is
parody I just want to make sure that
that race was not a it was not none it
feels like it's a real race but it's not
a real race but like I said imagine
imagine the outcome of the elections and
you begin to see these things but like
as soon as like the outcome of this one
I guarantee you know they're already
thinking because 10 years ahead they're
going to figure out how to redraw the
district lines and they're going to
figure out what new laws to put in place
to make sure that only a certain group
of people
can vote and not other people and that's
what they're going to continue to do and
that's
there is no Republicans have nothing to
offer they have no Solutions here you
know what the best way to look at is
uh
Republicans are like Elon Musk at
Twitter
non-solutions jam through thinking that
it's going to just fix the problem but
it only makes the problem worse and then
eventually that group or that entity has
to be replaced to make sure
that they cannot make those rules
anymore they cannot disenfranchise those
votes from other people like how [ __ ]
how much work the Republican Party does
to make sure that they all they
disenfranchise their own constituents to
make sure that they cannot vote is
asinine insane
um and yes I did promise Kalin that we
would bring this up
um I think I have the we can go to his
his Twitter account but uh we had we had
him on the show we actually did an
interview with him
um
uh and he won yeah um well we
interviewed him in his primary too right
this was before the gym sorry that's the
wrong clip I'm trying to find the uh
um go to his page uh someone but Johnny
um in Texas he won
um there was a there was rebuisters
being in Texas and
um he actually
he actually won where in the hell is his
Twitter yeah you got it okay send me
that send me the link there
um but we have we interviewed him in his
primary and we actually we were talking
to him about how Texas was blue
um because he really truly believed that
Texas was blue which and the
disappointing thing about last night was
one of my one of my disappointments was
that
um that that Beto did not win Texas even
as as much as he uh he worked so hard
but
um here you see the result 57 in this
district for Salman mojiani
um in against I don't know Joe
Livingston some crusty white dude yeah
um but you see that you see the change
here
um in this District in District 92 and
he worked hard and he and when he was on
our show he was talking about getting
out the vote and how important it was to
register people and engage in people
this is this is why I've been so so
confident is because when he came on the
show and he was talking to us about
engaging and finding people and just
talking to them like just talking to
them and asking them about what's
important to them why why voting is
important to them it it it does breed
democracy and democracy will spread and
when you have a party that is
anti-democracy that is election deniers
and they're just absolute vile pieces of
garbage then it actually has a huge
effect it a huge effect when you do
start to find people that are you know
generally will vote for Republicans but
they're like you know what democracy is
more important democracy is more
important it's more important and here's
things
for people who believe you know that
they they
people who think they can just win a
free and safe like a free and fair
election they do not work this hard to
to cast doubt on its result they do not
work this hard to suppress your vote
they do not work this hard to make sure
that a blue District now becomes a red
District because of one small little
area like the way in which they redraw
the lines is
unfair insane it you know we talked
about this the other day we talked about
this when we said Democrats are saying
with one loud voice even at the big
rally in in Philadelphia vote vote vote
vote vote and the Republicans are like
they're stealing it by voting like you
can tell and you can tell I mean they're
trying to make the case obviously to
vote for Democrats but they're not
forcing you to do it they're not like
telling you have to do it they're
literally just saying go out and
exercise your right to vote Google looks
like someone's saying uh by news
conference at 1 pm Eastern if that's the
case it's on right now I don't I don't
know if we have that on right now but
um so I'm not sure but there's some news
there but um here's here's an example of
a bonehead saying bone-headed [ __ ]
that'll get you not elected
um speaking of election deniers and an
absolute [ __ ] just a vile piece of
trash Carrie Lake
um here listen to what she says about
eight years in journal wisdom and what
she's going to do it's sorry not only be
of Arizona for four years
[Music]
the media as well what kind of Nazi is
this what I don't understand it did you
have you have some uh I was gonna yeah
it's uh one it seems to be 1pm
that was specific time at least because
I'm looking right now and I'm I'm uh
on YouTube and it says live in two hours
so oh okay so so at one PM Pacific time
so it would be 4 P.M East Coast time
right
um which they were asking about this in
the press conference yesterday
um the media was asking why isn't Biden
scheduled a press conference and all
this and you know I think he's being
very careful here because I actually
believe that he's not gonna he's gonna
try to have a Victory lap but he's not
going to try to pile on too much will
pile on I'll definitely pile him but I
don't think um Joe Biden's gonna pile on
here he's gonna say hey the country
heard me speak when I said democracy is
the most important thing and and that
that that that that is important and I
think that's that's where he's gonna go
with this I don't see that he would go
anywhere else
um with that as far as that goes did you
have any other clips that you wanted to
play today I know there's a ton out
there
um
I'm gonna go to the trends
um do we have word on this bobert count
yet I know they're really close no I
don't have anything I do have a photo uh
that I wanted to share with you or
rather two photos Ron Johnson is still
training too that's another reason that
one being counted uh yes but it looks
like he was declared the winner earlier
Ron Johnson is uh okay yeah so we have
um it looks like pull a decision desk
headquarters has him 99 reporting uh he
has I mean it was a very close race I
mean when you break it down
you've got it's one million it's kind of
like the diarrhea and puppy but a little
reverse here it's it's one million three
hundred and thirty four thousand six
hundred and eighty votes for Ron Johnson
and one million 307 282 votes for
Mandela Barn so like very close probably
this could probably be a recount though
maybe
I don't think it'll change it yeah I
don't think the rules are in Wisconsin
but
um yes it could qualify for a recount
it's just one of those things most most
are like a pointer under is what right
is what the threshold is yeah what do
you got on this clip here uh not a is it
I sent you a photo oh it's a photo okay
yeah it was just a photo from last night
it was a before and kind of what's going
on right now at the Lauren bobert oh yes
okay headquarters kind of party what
what was this the before when they
started to drop the ballots or was it
yeah this is before when it was it like
whoa we're in the lead oh we got a word
this gun is going real good guys does he
have his weiner oh no okay I didn't know
if this was at a boat I didn't know if
this had a bowling alley or not I have
no idea okay well um so there's there's
the before they're really excited yeah
they are [ __ ] ecstatic oh Oh yay now
let's see oh oh man the lighting has
changed the mood has changed they are it
looks like they're probably praying
right now I mean I it's it is it looks
like they looks like they need a bucket
and a mop because the floor is all whop
it is it is certainly a it's still a
very close race it'll still be encounted
um it'll probably get it get a uh a
recount ordered I mean right now they're
like four thousand five thousand votes
apart from each other which is insane
um but I think it is telling considering
how much that area was heavily leaning
red and heavily leaning for Trump in the
last election like two years I mean
within one year people within her own
District were like she doesn't care
about us she only cares about the fame
and fortune of being a a um a candidate
or a politician she's not actually been
a goddamn preacher for the like last
four months she goes to church and
church and she does the whole you know
walking around on stage like a rooster
and she's I mean I'm honestly hoping for
this this loss to come because there's
nothing left that she has she's she lost
her business the the landlord of the
building was like nope we're not
renewing the lease she lost the uh the
logo the rights to the logo or before
that even happened
um the logo of water or Shooters oh she
didn't she didn't renew it so somebody
came came in was like I own it now
and then the landlord was like yep don't
want you here anymore I'm not renewing
the lead that's kind of that's kind of
[ __ ] up though I gotta say that's kind
of [ __ ] up I mean look I mean it's
it's something that you can do but I
mean here's the thing here's the thing
I'm not a Lauren bobert fan either and
and she is just a vile piece of trash
but to to steal someone's logo it it
seems kind of I mean I'm just gonna say
it seems kind of low but yeah I'm not
sad about it no no I'm not sad about it
but also it's like that's why when you
run a business you know there are
certain people in charge to make sure
that you have all of your assets in
place to say great I've got my logo I've
got this property I've got this and that
these are all good I'm running this I'm
I'm being a good uh manager in terms of
actually
um you know taking control of of these
things that I own to make sure I don't
lose control of them right but Lauren
bober you know it was coming with a gun
no worries pew pew pew I don't really
care right like
throwing a oh my God it's they wanna you
know for for Lauren bobert and other
people who are like oh yeah guns make a
place more safe right you've got Blake
Masters who was like more guns make a
more civil society and it's like that is
insane more guns does not do that that
is not the answer to a problem and if
you bring guns into a restaurant you're
serving alcohol and beer and there's
whatever you got a bunch of people
[ __ ] waiters got guns everyone's
[ __ ] holding guns it's like that
scene from the office where it's Dwight
and
um
and Michael and uh and oh my God I'm
playing on his name Ed Helm's character
Andy Andy Bernard and they're all just
like pointing guns at each other and Pam
was there too and she walks away it's
just that it's just that Meme they're
all literally pointing guns at each
other in a restaurant to avoid a
confrontation and then eventually
somebody goes oh people my man and then
they go pee poo and then everyone just
shoots each other I mean I gotta say if
we would have lost every other race like
if it would have been a red wave just an
absolute Red Wave lose the house lose
the Senate lose every single
governorship lose our democracy but if
Lauren bobert would have lost I would be
like yeah that was a success I mean just
her losing is worth it right well
because early on last night even before
a lot of these races because I think you
know the theme of every election is too
close to call that's like literally the
the repeated phrase over and over again
too close to call too close to call and
last night even before they announced
these other races they were talking
about early on they're like whoa this
one came out of nowhere right and she's
behind and everyone and a lot of people
were like
I mean I'll be happy with that as I
don't I don't actually think it came out
of nowhere but you know that's the
narrative um here's democracy docket on
the and this was just a few minutes ago
that they posted this
um this is for the Arizona race
apparently it is still too close to call
it here
um while result they say while results
are still being counted we'll keep you
updated as developments happen races in
Nevada and Arizona including the crucial
Governor's contest between Secretary of
State Katie Hobbs which is the
Democratic nominee for governor and
Kerry Lake the crazy q and honor
um uh candidate for governor have not
yet been called so
um looks like those races have not been
called yet these are crucial races the
Nevada Senate the Arizona Senate
um and the Wisconsin Senate because
really
um it depends on if Warnock gets in a
runoff or not which it looks like it's
possible the math is possible for him
not to do a runoff
um he's either going to win or is this
going to be a runoff one of the other
here
um Herschel Walker is not going to win
this race with this count it's going to
either be Warnock wins with over 50 or
they go to a runoff now with that one
seat being held if there's not a runoff
if he gets over 50 percent because in
the state of Georgia you have to get 50
to to win the race
um if he does do that and he secures
that seat and Ron Johnson has secured
um uh Wisconsin now what we're going to
be looking at is uh Nevada and Arizona
those two seats are going to be the ones
because uh Republicans are going to have
to take those seats
um to steal it away there's basically
four or three or four seats but now if
those races dropped do we have can you
find if we have word on Georgia while
we're still going here yeah um I mean
last night when I went to bed it was
Gabriel Sterling said we're right well
but this morning they're counting more
and he actually popped over 50 percent
uh Warnock did yeah but that was about
an hour before we went on air and it was
popping back and forth between Warnock
being over 50 and another 50 or 50.
um with the count that they had it was
it was going back and forth now I'm sure
I'm sure if Herschel Walker can figure
out what a recount is he may ask for one
um I don't I have no idea again what the
rules are exactly there in Georgia but
it's very clear that Georgians did not
appreciate Herschel Walker being in that
race right
um the other thing I was hearing last
night from some people uh which is
insane they're like oh yeah the fact
that
these uh these stories came out about
Herschel Walker having abortions or
paying for abortions and denying it
really really
put a sour taste in my mouth and I voted
for Herschel Walker because everyone was
being mean to Herschel Walker
you're saying that people in Georgia
went and voted for him because he's a
[ __ ] box yeah so they were they were
talking to people last night they were
at this the the the Herschel Walker kind
of
um party HQ and they were talking to
people and they were like oh yeah we uh
we voted for Warnock because
um of some of the like our decision was
literally made at the last minute and a
lot of it felt like we had a new energy
in the campaign because of these people
that were voting for him and they were
like yeah we talked to some people last
night and they were saying how they felt
like it was unfairly attacked on on uh
or Herschel walk was unfairly attacked
and they had this sudden energy to be
like you know what I'm gonna vote for
Herschel Walker because this is not I'm
like what are we doing this guy is
literally unqualified and a walking
hypocrite in terms of talking about how
abortion should not be legal we should
have a 15-week uh abortion ban
but then he's also the guy that's like
but if I'm getting abortion or paying
for an abortion then it's totally cool
and I've never paid for an abortion in
my life and you can't say diff like
it's you know I think I think though
there's something deep underlying about
this though
what it tells me is that the
Conservative Christian vote the white
nationalist you know Christian white
Christian nationalists in this country
they are not Tethered to any kind of
actual religious principle and the
reason why is because
Warnock is literally a reverend like he
before he became a politician his entire
[ __ ] life was devoted to Jesus Christ
right which I'm I'm not a religious
person I'm an atheist
um which you know to each his own I'm
not saying that that someone being a
Christian automatically makes them a
[ __ ] box but you really have to start to
question it these days because of this
reason
so they literally said I'm gonna go vote
for Herschel Walker because I'm a
Christian and he's the exact opposite of
what I'm saying I want to have where
Warnock is the thing that you say you
want to have it just it makes no sense
and it only tells me that a big portion
of the foundation of the Republican vote
has no principles which is which is why
well right but but here's the thing
though that's that's not bad for our
democracy what I mean by that is these
people have have uncoupled themselves
from any kind of principle they're gonna
find a hard way to actually build a
coalition around I don't know things
like principles like you can't if you
are absolutely untethered from a world
where you you are untethered from
reality and any kind of foundation or
principles whatsoever in your beliefs
you are not going to be able to form
coalitions to win across the country
it's just not going to happen we've seen
that with trumpism that is what this is
that is what last night and that is what
happened last night is that they cannot
put together an actual Coalition that
can win national races and the reason a
national body races and even Statewide
races I mean Jesus Christ think about
this for a second the three states that
they really wanted the governor's race
is in so that they could cheat in 2024
is Pennsylvania Michigan and Arizona
that's the ones they wanted they're
probably not going to get any of those
the only one that they still have on the
map
is Kerry Lake the craziest of the crazy
of the crazies and Arizona basically
said you know what we're Republican here
but you're a [ __ ] nut job yeah like
we're crazy but we're not that crazy
you're a [ __ ] nut job and I believe
that really truly is the story here is
that they really have pared down their
base so they whittled it down so far to
people who are either white supremacists
and they they just are [ __ ] bigots
are they are they absolutely have no
[ __ ] tie to reality or principles and
that is not going to be a coalition that
you can [ __ ] win national races with
and that's why I was so confident in
this race because it's the first time
that this country got to speak with one
National voice against trumpism after
January 6. we had eight million more
[ __ ] people vote for Joe Biden and it
wasn't because they liked Joe Biden
that's and and last night people voting
for Democrats aren't fans of Joe Biden
they [ __ ] know the danger of trumpism
and these [ __ ] whack-a-doos having
anything to do with our government and
our policies and that's what happens I
mean that's what happens when you've got
you know there were some people here's
that there were some people like hey I
don't want to campaign with Biden
there's some people like yeah come
campaign with me but when it comes to
Trump
he was like nope I'm coming I don't care
like I'm gonna campaign for you and I'm
gonna come and cry my tears on your
stage and talk about myself and I'm
gonna talk about my [ __ ] I'm gonna put
my baggage out there for everyone to
hear and yeah maybe some people will
cheer and maybe some people will go
rah-rah here's some money but at the end
of the day when it actually comes down
to these rallies if you were it's like
Trump rallies and the candidates he
endorses
really remind me of an NFL game right
you've got like or a Super Bowl or
whatever you're like a major game where
you've got three hours that's how
[ __ ] long it is three hours but it's
filled with commercials and timeouts and
half time and all this stuff and when
you really compile you're like oh
there's only like 45 minutes of actual
play time but at a trump rally you're
like there's actually only like
10 minutes of people actually [ __ ]
talking and the other two and a half
hours is comprised of them waiting and
Trump talking for over an hour
potentially and them interviewing
interviewing all the groupies that
exactly and that's the other thing too
that I think is such a [ __ ] fraud and
and I think that got exposed in the
final months here is that all these
people go into these Trump rallies it's
all the same [ __ ] it's all the
same [ __ ] there's no movement
Aaron points it out here beautifully he
says so Trump initially tried to just
lie about how great the midterms were
for him but the absurdity of these fake
figures might have been a bit much even
for him as today he's gone radio silent
amid reports he's fuming so he's pissed
off which he should be because it's his
fault he should take blame for this and
we should blame him I hope Mitch
McConnell and Kevin McCarthy are able to
place blame on him and I hope he runs
while it happens uh Aaron goes on to say
meanwhile uh foxlotter's Breeze Our
slathers Praise over DeSantis they love
DeSantis now interesting times here's
the actual
uh tweet this was about 11 hours ago I
think
um from from the Cheeto desk q and honor
here's his fake figures 174 wins and
nine losses it's all [ __ ] not even
close and a great evening yeah not nope
not at all and the fake news media
together with their partner in crime the
Democrats are doing everything possible
to play it down amazing job by some
really fantastic candidates this is not
even close to it's really it's really
hard when all of the uh you know places
like Fox News are admitting yeah that
was a loss that was pretty devastating
he didn't do enough or you know again it
really comes down to this fact of like
Trump shot himself on the foot by going
to the and doing these rallies and
talking
for these people these candidates where
you barely even see because again it's
like a football game which you know is
like scheduled by the way by the way
another great loss was Majewski Majewski
oh my boy yeah my boy J.R Majewski he
lost bigly no that's funny so here's
here's what I say before we go uh
because I don't know if fake Gabe is
still here or not because I haven't been
asking where fake Gabe is and he's yeah
he probably he probably left I would
really like to get fake Gabe's take on
this this [ __ ] post
um to see if he he reflects this or not
because that's what we're gonna see
going forward and I think that's the
most important thing about leaning into
your democracy we have to keep leaning
in this is not over even if Democrats
manage to pull the numbers together to
have the house which I think they can do
here still I think we're still in that
that territory
um because there were plus or minus 10
and that was a couple hours ago so uh in
the in the in the projections so it's
still they're still going to be able to
put a win together and mainly it's
because of your state California they're
still doing some tabulations some of
those races
um even Katie borders uh unsure she's
won yet or not I don't know if they've
finalized that race but here's what I
want to say
to everyone out there be very confident
this is great this is great news this is
exactly what we wanted to have happen
because democracy one
democracy one and it's only because this
lying [ __ ] has to lie to make
himself look good to make you know that
we [ __ ] won and that is the most
important thing that I want you to take
out of what happened in this election is
that democracy won the pro-democracy
Coalition banded together they did what
they had to do to tell the country no to
trumpism and we have to continue we have
to lean in I hope he runs I I really
hope that you are with me now in this
effort to get Donald Trump to run for
president against Ron DeSantis this is
what we want this is what we want for
democracy he's gonna make this
announcement next week on when or on
Tuesday November 15th are you sure you
won't announce that he's gonna announce
that he'll announce in January or
something I wouldn't do well here's the
thing I wouldn't be surprised if he does
announce that he's going to announce or
that he cancels it last minute or
whatever but we have to remember he was
hoping for a red wave to push him in
because what he needed was he needed the
validation because right now if he
announces or even before if he was
announcing the RNC was like we're not
paying we're not paying for your legal
bills but what he needed was a huge
[ __ ] win and he needed all of the
election Liars to win to prove look at
the [ __ ] that I can bring to the table
and if he had that then maybe the RNC
would say okay look you're [ __ ] crazy
but clearly this is the path that we
need this is the crate this is the crazy
we got this is the crazy however all
almost all of the candidate candidates
that Trump has picked have either lost
or are currently losing as they're being
tabulated so right now the RNC is like
yeah [ __ ] now we're not doing that [ __ ]
and so Trump next week on his
announcement whatever it's going to be
this Grand announcement at Mar-A-Lago on
November 15th Tuesday
what does he do I don't know because
look he's got over leverage I want him
to run I want him to run leverage I
wanted to run Gabe I want him to run I
want him to run as well I want him to be
so [ __ ] like nine ways to [ __ ]
Sunday or whatever eight ways to Sunday
however you know what an hour many ways
however many ways countless ways but it
is something where you know Donald Trump
thought he was going to come in with a
win and he thought he was going to bring
all these election Liars with them and
use it as leverage and make a bet
against the RNC to say uh look if you
don't back me now then I'm gonna take
all these people away right I'll run as
an independent or some [ __ ] like that I
don't know but that is something where
you look at it he has nothing he has a
couple wins here and there but clearly
not enough to prove to the Republican
Party hey guys look if I announce now I
can Corral these people I can really
work on it five to six because that's he
also has a five to six month head start
on Ron DeSantis because Ron DeSantis
can't just announce
next year and be like or in the
beginning of next year when his term
renews and say I'm running for president
yeah but I believe but I don't think
that's a bad thing I actually think it
gives people reason why not to like
Trump if he's out there for six months
pushing because he's got to run against
someone and he can't run against Biden
he's gonna have to run against a
Republican and the obvious Republican
run against his DeSantis so he's going
to start disparaging DeSantis and it's
really going to show how close-knit
their Coalition is which it's not
because they're not adhered to any
reality or any principle everyone thanks
for joining us today tomorrow same time
same place
Surf's Up [ __ ] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] em [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's mewborn headass Beacon